Speaker 1: One of the things that we've
been talking about is Donald Trump's
endorsement record. Donald Trump and others tout
the power of the Trump endorsement. And indeed,
Donald Trump over the last 48 hours has
been posting uncontrollably, uncontrollably
to his platform. Truth, Social Trust, essential,
and it is all about his supposed endorsement
record. Check this out. Trump spending a lot of
time there. Trump candidates dominate Tuesday's
primary elections. Molly Hemingway. Republicans
need to understand why its prospects are
so good. Trump reshaped the party. He's the
savior as far as Trump wants you to believe.
Trump 2024 crush the establishment, retweeting all
sorts of very true thing, all sorts of different
stuff. Trump endorsed candidates are ready to take
back our country, I guess quoting Carrie Lake or
who knows who? Blake Masters Wins Arizona
Republican Senate Primary. Again, the idea is
thanks to Trump there. Rusty Bowers, January 6th
star witness loses Republican Primary in Arizona.
The idea there is not a Trump endorsed guy and
he lost. Trump nod spurs Dixon to runaway win
in Michigan. He's responsible there. Trump backed
Gibbs. This is the guy I interviewed. Trump backed
Gibbs ousts Meyer in Michigan Republican race for
Congress. On and just if you scroll down troth
essential it is just post after post after post
of Donald Trump taking credit for all of these
different victories. Trump candidates dominate
Tuesday primaries again big historic win for Trump
endorsed candidates across the country. Now 15 and
O in Senate primaries. Perfect records in Arizona,
Kansas, Michigan and Missouri. Congratulations to
our mag. This i could just go and go and go. I'm
not going to subject you to this. Not going
to subjected to this. So what is the truth
about Donald Trump's endorsement
record? Well, there's two sides to this.
One side of it are just the numbers, like are the
numbers actually as good as Donald Trump claims?
And the second part would be, even if the numbers
are as good as he claims. Are they meaningful? Are
they statistically significant when you consider
the circumstances? Let's go through it one by one.
So first and foremost, Ballot Pdea maintains
a page. The endorsements of Donald Trump.
During Trump's presidency, there were 305
endorsements. Since Trump left office, there have
been 237 additional endorsements. Okay, so this
year, Trump's record is 92%. That's a good record.
No question about it. We'll get back to that in
2020. Trump's endorsement record was 77% in 2019.
It was 43% in those special elections
in 2018, Trump's record was 58%.
So let me explain to you what this is all about.
All right. When Donald Trump was actually making
endorsements in general elections where they were
actually contested races, he was basically 5050.
So it's almost like a coin flip. Okay. If you
consider that Trump endorsed some incumbents there
and that Trump made some endorsements of
individuals who were clearly the favorite
at the time of the endorsement, barely 5050 isn't
particularly impressive. It's just it's a little
bit better than a coin flip. And a lot of the
times he's endorsing people who sort of like
should win anyway because they've raised the most
money. They're the clear front runners, they're
the incumbents. So that's number one. If you look
at 2022, Trump's record is significantly better
in the primaries because Donald Trump is
sometimes getting behind the obvious leader.
Sometimes that's an incumbent, and we
know about the power of incumbency.
And sometimes Trump is waiting until the absolute
last moment. And sometimes it's very mushy, like,
for example, when he endorsed Eric in Missouri.
And two, if not three of the leading candidates
were named Eric, like, are we counting that as
a win? I'm not sure whether that counts here.
So it's not a particularly interesting endorsement
story. Trump's endorsement history is very 5050.
And then in particular, in 2022, there's this bias
to just supporting the person already likely to
win. Now, I will give Trump credit. There are
a handful of candidates who were not winning
when Trump endorsed them, and then they ended
up winning. And there's no doubt that Trump's
endorsement has some power. The question is going
to be the general election, the general election
in the general election endorsements in 2022.
Trump is over ten. He's made ten endorsements
in general elections where it's a Democrat
versus a Republican, and he lost every single
one. He doesn't talk about that. So we're going
to pay attention to that very closely as well.